le quiero empezar planteando algo que
comentó un funcionario de Estados Unidos
y es que avanzó que el g7 iba a imponer
nuevas sanciones a Rusia pero le
pregunto qué queda por hacer en este
ámbito
Bueno en realidad no sabemos con
precisión Qué tipo de sanciones van a
aplicar pero hasta ahora las sanciones
no han surtido el efecto esperado en
primer lugar diez rondas de sanciones y
no han surtido el efecto esperado no han
debilitado la economía rusa como se
esperaba Y en segundo lugar ha tenido un
efecto Boomerang sobre la economía
internacional en general entonces la
aplicación de sanciones probablemente se
decida pero más como un gesto simbólico
porque la efectividad de estas es
bastante limitado ahora lo paradójico Es
que esto se va a dar en un contexto en
donde ya hay ciertas tensiones dentro
del g7 no solo con respecto a Cómo
manejar el tema de la guerra en Ucrania
algunos están ya avanzando en el sentido
de proponer algún tipo de acuerdo para
salir de la situación
Estados Unidos Precisamente es el que
más promueve todavía la continuación de
la guerra y por otro lado esto coincide
con una reunión muy importante que tiene
el presidente con los países de Asia
central y que de alguna manera refleja
en ambos casos dado que en el G están
invitando a Brasil Indonesia India un
una atención en términos de quién se
gana aliados en el sur global entre el
eje Rusia china por un lado y lo que es
el bloque euroasiático y por otro lado
el g7 y yo diría más Quizás los bricks
versus el g7 en el marco del g20 sí
Andrés ahora comentaremos esta reunión
de Pin con las ex repúblicas soviéticas
pero antes le quiero plantear sobre la
mesa del g7 también va a estar la
petición de Ucrania de aviones a de
combate
f-16-17 sobre el que también hay ciertas
discrepancias entre los propios miembros
del g7 que se espera en este sentido
yo creo que hay discrepancias claras
dentro del g7 con respecto a cómo
continuar el apoyo a Ucrania en el marco
de la agresión de Rusia y de la guerra
que se ha desatado y en eso hay
posiciones distintas percepciones
distintas y yo creo que la posición más
dura es la mantenida por Estados Unidos
y por Gran Bretaña como lo señalaba en
donde no están dispuestos a
abrir un frente que permita algún tipo
de diálogo y avanzar en algún tipo de
armisticio previo algún tipo de acuerdo
de paz Entonces yo creo que además a
esto se suma que el otro gran tema junto
con la Guerra de Ucrania va a ser el
tema de Cómo contener a China y en esto
también hay muchas cosas en juego y
diferencias y discrepancias muy marcadas
entre los miembros del g7 la mejor
prueba de eso es
la los comentarios hechos por el
presidente en China durante su visita sí
unos comentarios que levantaron mucha en
Estados Unidos pero precisamente
hablando de China Qué mensaje
mandando a los líderes de los países de
Asia central en repúblicas soviéticas en
ausencia de Rusia en esta en esta
reunión yo creo que hay una percepción
un poco
distorsionada desde occidente con
respecto a la actuación de China y Rusia
en el marco de eurasia eh Rusia
evidentemente está concentrando su
atención en el escenario de guerra en
Ucrania Pero eso la afecta en su
relación con los países miembros de la
unión económica euroasiática de la
organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva y de la misma organización de
cooperación de shangay pero no nos
olvidemos que la organización de
cooperación de Shanghai donde están
Rusia y China como los principales
motores de esta organización en el marco
euroasiático para garantizar la no
inclusión de la presencia occidental y
particularmente de Estados Unidos en
eurasia
han estado trabajando conjuntamente
China y Rusia en esto desde el año 2001
prácticamente y obviamente
la visita la la Perdón la reunión de
chimpín con los países de Asia central
de alguna manera responde a un interés
de preservar ese espacio fuera de la
influencia occidental y desde luego
promover sus propios intereses del punto
de vista económico en donde Sí puede
haber algún tipo de roces con Rusia que
considera eso parte de el equivalente en
nuestro caso de patio trasero de de
Rusia